all right
let's give this a spin shall we so
hopefully
this was the easy part okay in some
senses this is just all right i
recognize this form
i need to put these two together right
three and four they add to seven
multiply through twelve you end up at
this quadratic
okay um there'd probably be one mark for
getting to this point by the way
then you have to solve the quadratic and
here's where you end up
now what's unusual about this is when
you have a look at these two solutions
okay
one of them obviously is negative right
minus three
minus root three they're both negative
so when you put them together
it's even more negative so we kind of
know yeah we should reject that one
but when you have a look at the other
one let's put it up up here
the other solution right the more
positive the two solutions
is still negative right it's still
negative and we looked before we said
you should reject negative answers
right um you know even not knowing what
this number is
root three is smaller than three it has
to be right by definition
so therefore when you add it you're
still going to be whatever minus 1.3
i'm not sure what roughly it is okay um
because root three is
one point seven three ish okay so you're
still negative
that's weird but it's okay
x can still be equal to this number even
though it's negative
right there is actually a solution to
this the question is why
why do we accept a negative solution
here whereas before i just
label the point of set negative
solutions um
dorian got is it because when you do the
restrictions on like the separate logs
the biggest
the most restrictive one is x is greater
than that
good okay so let's you've got one two
three log functions therefore you've got
one two three
restrictions implied okay and just
before we get to your explanation which
is perfect
um each one is x is greater than
negative four
x is greater than negative three and x
is greater than negative
six okay so you can see that x is
greater than negative three is the most
picky one
right but it still means you can accept
negative one negative two negative two
point nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
they're all okay
because they satisfy all three of the
inequalities you satisfy this one you
satisfied all three
okay so being that like this is minus
three plus something
and so long as you're greater than minus
three you're okay that's why this
solution
is all right so i would say at this
point but
x is greater than negative three so we
reject the one that's to the left of
negative three but we accept the one
that's to the right it makes sense now
just before we leave off this this is
worth illustrating one more problem
right the first the first mistake you
can make with this
is just to say just off hand say reject
all solutions right because oh they're
both negative
so therefore they're both rubbish that's
the first thing you're equipped now to
not make that mistake
but there's an opposite problem that
students often make as well
let's think about this by the way these
two i always try and encourage you to
think visually as much as you can
okay so what you're really finding is
the sum
of two log functions right which by the
way
just looks like another log function
right when does it intersect
with this other log function does that
make sense that's what you're really
finding
okay so therefore if i just think about
the right hand one okay log base 2
x 6 okay we know what
shape and what position the normal log
base 2 of x
curve has it's over here right so when i
do x 6 what difference
it shifts doesn't it shifts to the left
6 units it's kind of implied by this
restriction
see this greater than minus 6. so i
could be all the way over here
at -6 and i'll have some kind of shape
ish like that now i'm looking for a
point of intersection
it just so happens that for this
particular one minus three
plus root three so that's minus one
point three ish so i'm intersecting
around
i'm pretty sure the graphs look
something like this
okay so bam you found your point of
intersection right
and this other solution that you
rejected is somewhere over here not
relevant
okay um or it's actually around here
but there's another problem you can run
into right
um you might get to this point suppose
it's all different numbers you look at
this
and you say okay i need to check if
these solutions are valid or not
i know you shouldn't just reject them
out of hand right
i'll just take the more positive one
i'll just take that one because there
ought to be a there ought to be an
intersection right
and so if there's going to be one not
two it should be the one that's
more positive okay there's a problem
with that
um i have a point of section right but i
don't have to
i could just as easily last night as i
was ticking around on them
on desmos and you can do the same i can
just as easily
make a pair of functions over here you
just have to fiddle with the numbers a
little bit
that's going to look something like this
here's my um
here's my log base 2
of x plus 6 it doesn't take that much
effort to come up with a function that
looks like this
okay log base 2 of something else right
and it never intersects right you will
get to this point
you'll get to this point and when you
check both of the solutions you arrive
at from your quadratic
against these restrictions that have
been implied none of them will satisfy
because there are no points of
intersection why should there be it's
not necessary
right it's just that we give you a
disproportionate number of questions
that have solutions right but in real
life just as many problems
don't have solutions as the ones that do
okay
so in summary number one when you have a
quadratic don't blindly assess no
solutions
okay don't just say oh yes of course i
reached here i was solving quadratic
quadratics always have two solutions
your real question was a log question so
use these restrictions
secondly don't just blindly accept the
more positive one
okay um if you've got something like
this there may be no solutions at all
and you just have to say
no real solutions based on your
restrictions
yes does that mean that even though um
one of them might satisfy the frame like
the um
range when you start it back in it might
not work
no if it doesn't if it doesn't work it's
because it won't satisfy the domain i
think is what you're mentioning
okay um and then what that means is when
you square this
having this square means i have another
version of this graph over here which is
why you get another point of
intersection
right but it's not really there okay so
what you'll get is something which
doesn't really satisfy any of these
off of these values over here okay